so we partner with planet 13.  they have the space to accommodate this  huge drive  and we have vendors like green light  productions  us rove trendy medicine  nature's chemistry and so many others  that donated products  to make this happen it'll be going to  las vegas rescue mission  and safe nest oh the response has been  amazing we received over 30  000 cans toys and food repair tools  so we decided to combine everything and  just do one huge drive  and after this we get to wrap all the  gifts  and turn them into all the children on  december 19th these are holiday times  this is  2020 it's been a rough year for families  and everybody in las vegas  you know taking a hit with covet and  everything so we figured what way can we  give back more and we figured if we can  work well with great partners we can  really do something magical and you know  having everybody donate over 30 000 cans  within two and a half weeks is unheard  of